вот что вы делаете на самом деле когда
вы даёте кому-то в долг человек когда
попадает в долговую яму или когда он
кругом кому-то должен Я считаю что в
такой ситуации он виноват прежде всего
сам это не болезнь которая Дана ему как
наказание или свыше или которой он не
может управлять любое попадание в
долговую яму или в долг Я считаю это
следствие неправильно и неэффективно
принятых ранее решений и эти решения
были принятым поэтому когда к вам
обращаются за деньгами и просят у вас
долг и вы зачастую не можете отказать и
вот мы сегодня об этом поговорим к Каким
плохим последствиям
приводят деньги данные вами в долг когда
человек погряз в долгах когда кругом у
него долги когда банки его преследуют
коллекторы либо он попал в
это вина самого человека вернее даже не
столько вина человека а это следствие
его неправильных решений решений которые
были неэффективны поэтому здесь не надо
человеку который оказался в долгах
винить просто так себя когда вы
обвиняете просто себя вы просто рушите и
снижается свою самооценку и благодаря
этому вам тяжелее будет вылез из Долгов
поэтому прежде всего вам нужно не себя
обвинить а
Какие конкретно убеждения привели вас к
неэффективным решениям которые загнали
вас в долги Давайте поговорим об этом
более подробно очень часто ко мне тоже
обращаются люди за деньгами и я для себя
даже создал несколько алгоритмов и когда
ко мне человек
обращается за деньгами Я прежде всего
спрашиваю задаю ему три вопроса что он
просит он просит
долбо инвестиции либо он просит помощь
если человек просит помощь то у меня там
есть алгоритмы помощь Я оказываю двух
видов одна вид - это закат это в рамках
моей Веры там есть строго определённый
список людей которым я могу оказывать
помощь и второй вид Садака - это помощь
которую я оказываю нуждающимся людям но
там тоже целый список я оказываю это
через благотворительный фонд целый
список нуждающихся и понятно что если
человек не на нуждается как люди в том
списке то я ему говорю Ну почему ты
считаешь
себя Что ты имеешь больше прав на эту
помощь чем вот этот список всех этих
людей я просто говорю что ты знаешь я
помощь оказываю через благотворительный
фонд такой-то Это то что касается помощи
там у меня всё отлажена алгоритм Понятно
Бывает так что человек говорит Нет нет
нет я не помощь хорошо Дай мне
инвестиции
вот часто Вот разговор именно так и
происходит то есть сначала просто просит
денег потом я начинаю уточнять В каком
виде это помощь инвестиции либо долг Он
начинает говорить просто помоги Потом я
ему объясняю что помочь не могу по
таким-то причинам он начинает говорить
тогда дай мне инвестиции и тут у меня
тоже есть алгоритм Я говорю если тебе
нужны инвестиции то подай заявку подай
бизнес-план У нас есть Требования по
нашим стандартам подаёшь в
инвестиционный комитет там мы выносим на
инвестиционном комитете рассматриваем
если ты получаешь одобрение то дальше
уже мы начинаем с тобой работать понятно
что человеку не хочется заморачиваться
со всем этим и он тогда скатывается на
третью часть и говорит Ну дай мне в долг
и когда у меня просят долг я очень часто
говорю ты знаешь во-первых мой принцип А
никому не дога не давать в долг Потому
что есть народное правило хочешь а
потерять друга Дай ему в долг Но к
сожалению это психология Дело в том что
когда человек берёт в долг Он только в
момент получения денег испытывает
благодарность А дальше этот долг на него
давит и является бременем естественно
человек не привык обычно тот человек
который попал в долго яму а он туда
попал не с проста а из-за своего
мышления в его мышлении в его картине
мира виноват не он сам и не его
убеждения а виноват тот кому он должен
вернуть деньги по этому поводу наш
мудрый народ сделал такую пословицу
которая звучит так
что ты всегда берёшь чужие а отдаёшь
свои
поэтому когда люди начинают возвращать
долг они кредитора воспринимают как
врага таким образом давая в долг вы
финансово стимулирует человека стать
вашим врагом Вы наверное сами это много
раз с этим сталкивались и сами это
замечали
обязательно Напишите в комментариях ваши
случаи Как у вас было наверняка я уверен
это 100% работает везде в любых странах
с любыми людьми очень редко можно
встретить людей которые взяли в долг и с
радостью возвращают но просто мне самому
интересно Напишите в комментариях случаи
из вашей жизни когда вы давали в долг и
чем это заканчивалось А мы продолжим
дальше Вторая большая
проблема когда человек просит в долг Он
исет чувство студа и унижения и
психологически мы так устроены что мы
потом воспринимаем те события и тех
людей когда мы испытывали чувство суда и
унижения мы воспринимаем как враждебное
и мы всячески избегаем подобных ситуаций
и подобных людей таким образом когда
человек у вас просит в долг и
вы именно в тот момент когда он уже
просит он уже чувствует себя униженным и
он уже чувствует себя
положе испытываю глубокий стыд то что
вы вернее не вы его заставили А то что
он при вас это испытывает или испытывает
перед вами потом оборачивается против
вас и вы знаете интересный такой момент
Я заметил что когда вы отказываете Я
даже по глазам очень часто видел человек
как бы даже получает
определённое там не то что
удовлетворение такое его как будто
чуть-чуть отпускает Я думаю почему так
происходит Вроде я же отказал а
происходит Вот почему Очень часто он в
долг просит потому что он в голове у
себя Думает я должен попросить я должен
попросить в результате он через это
должен идёт на эти унижения и стыд И
когда я ему отказываю у него вдруг
появляется спасительное убеждение
которое спасает его эго и которое гласит
не я один оказывается говнюк а он тоже
говнюк Вот у него есть деньги он мог мне
помочь а он мне отказал Так что Ещё
неизвестно Кто больше говнюк и вот это
такое отмазка оправдание А тому стыду и
унижение которою он пережил у него
теперь есть причина
а спасти своё лицо перед самим собой и
третья проблема Я считаю это самая
основная проблема первые две проблемы -
это больше психологические А третья
самая большая проблема в том что если
человек попал в долг И в долги прот или
просто в тяжёлую ситуацию и у вас а
просит долг то вы даёте ему только
временное обезбаливающее вы не даёте
человеку пройти урок не даёте извлечь
урок из этой жизненной ситуации вы даёте
временно обезбаливающее и таким образом
как бы подсаживается его как на
очередную дозу наркотика так как он
увидел вот у него проблема он взял у вас
деньги быстренько её решил то у него
сформируется неправильный паттерн
поведения в следующий раз когда с такой
же ситуацией сталкивается он начинает
думать не как проблему решить а он
начинает думать где занять и очень часто
те люди которые просят долг - это как
правило серийные должники они привыкли
брать в долг они привыкли перезалить они
не привыкли противостоять проблеме и
решать её поэтому давая деньги в долг
человеку вы вредите ему вы даёте
временное обезбаливающее и не позволяете
человеку расти потому что любая проблема
является источником роста человека
просто держите эту мысль у себя в голове
и тогда вам легче будет а обосновать
свой отказ Ну для себя Потому что прежде
чем отказать кому-то другому Вы должны
найти аргументы для себя Почему вы
должны ему отказать потому что очень
часто люди не могут отказать потому что
они считают что Ну они стыдятся своего
отказа но то что Я отказал это они
думают что если Я отказал значит я
черствый я значит жестокий значит я
жадный и так далее и так далее и очень
часто люди дают в долг не из-за того что
они вник в ситуацию другого а из-за того
чтобы не думать о себе так плохо но если
вы будете в голове держать Что давать
долг человеку любому человеку это
останавливать его развитие и не давать
ему пройти свой жизненный
тогда вам легче будет отказывать давать
долг Ставьте лайк подписывайтесь на
канал А мы пойдём дальше и вы
узнаете о самом лучшем способе
отказывать людям когда просят у вас долг
который я сам использую алгоритм отказом
Это я сам себе такое составил Из своего
опыта я понял такую вещь когда человек
приходит и просит у вас долг бывают
разные ситуации бывает ситуация что он
хочет вылез из других долгов то есть
перезавантаження
первое что я обычно в таких ситуациях
говорю первое Я обычно говорю я тебя
понимаю я я тебя понимаю Я сам был в
такой ситуации У каждого В жизни такое
может случиться и это не не только твоя
проблема Это такая проблема случается у
всех людей то есть первое нужно проявить
сочувствие Потому что если вы сразу же
начнёте лезть к нему со своими советами
то вы просто он отвернётся и вы просто
испорти испортите отношения поэтому
первые правило Когда у вас просят л
всегда проявите понимание и Сочувствие
это первое второе надо сказать что вы
Цените ваши отношения Надо сказать что
Ты знаешь я очень ценю наши отношения И
я не хочу чтобы долг их испортил потому
что есть народное правило хочешь
потерять друга Дай ему в долг народ это
не зря придумал и я знаю очень много
психологических факторов Почему
А долг испортит наши отношения поэтому
второе обязательно подчеркните то
насколько вы Цените
а отношения третье
а обязательно надо сказать Так что Да я
тоже это прошёл Я ценю наши отношения и
ты знаешь каждый раз когда я был в такой
ситуации и выходил из неё я становился
крепче становился сильнее Поэтому если
ты оказался в такой ситуации то это
классный урок Это хороший урок для того
чтобы стать лучше Пройди этот урок пойми
В чём был корень ошибки Почему ты
оказался в такой ситуации поэтому не
рассматриваю это как Трагедию а
рассматривайте
я мысленно
взвешивать и например он пришёл мне
просить там условно 50.000 долларов Ну
это может быть родственник друг Ну с
улицы там навряд ли кто-то придёт это же
обязательно кто-то либо друзья либо
знакомые либо родственники вы сразу
смотрите и внутри себя в это же время
взвешивается сколько этому человеку ты
мог бы просто подарить вот он прил там
ему не хватает на квартиру там или
что-то там
про себя взвесил думае Ну 5000 долларов
могу или четвёртым пунктом ты говоришь
Ты знаешь вот чтобы не быть совсем
безучастным к твоей ситуации прими от
меня вот этот чистосердечный подарок
даёте ему 5000 долларов вместо п и таким
образом он становится благодарным потому
что он получил не долг А подарок
бесплатные деньги у него нету аргументов
на вас
дли он не станет ШИМ врагом потому ему
недо воз деньги таким образом Вы спасли
отношения малой кровью вместо того чтобы
у вас был выбор либо отдать 50.000
долларов и нажить врага либо отказать
полностью не дав ему ничего и испортив
отношения а вот благодаря этому
алгоритму вы сохраняете отношения и
обходите с малой кровью А подскажите
если уже так получилось вот близкий друг
либо родственник попросил в долг м дали
денег не смогли отказать и понимаете что
человек уже перестал отвечать начинает
так вот как-то юлить выходит на связь
вообще и понимаете что Ну всё сейчас
отношения испортятся а отношения портить
Ну очень не хочется вот в этой уже
ситуации многие наверное в такой
ситуации как-то бывали либо есть сейчас
как быть уже вот в конкретно такой
сложив ситуации как не испортить
отношения Когда кто-то уже взял в долг и
уже очевидно что не особо-то он может
или готов возвращать а отношения портить
не хочется в той ситуации Если вы уже
дали кому-то в долг и он избегает
выплаты долга всячески избегает вас там
не выходит на контакты и так далее И вам
при этом не хочется портить отношения с
ним либо Бывает так что вы родственники
и вы не можете портить отношения в таких
ситуациях я обычно встречаюсь с этим
человеком и говорю ты знаешь я понимаю у
тебя сейчас определённые трудности и так
далее Я ему говорю так вернёшь мне тогда
когда ты сможешь когда у тебя ситуация
улучшится и это даёт ему пространство
во-первых а не возвращать никогда но
люди редко так поступают второе - это
возвращать в комфортном ему режиме и
третье - это даёт ему ну высокую степень
я бы сказал так благодарности вам вы
должны у себя мысленно списать эти
деньги так и так эти деньги списаны Вы
Не вернёте их потому что если человек
попал в затруднительный ситуацию то
неважно там хоть вы 10 решений судов
вынесете хоть вы что будете делать хоть
15 напоминаний в день он не сможет вам
вернуть вы просто испортите отношения
так вот чтобы сохранить отношения и в то
же время оставить хоть какой-то шанс
возврата хоть какой-то части этих денег
лучше всего поступить именно так